-Welcome to "The Tonight Show,"
everybody. I'm Jimmy Fallon.
Thank you so much for tuning in.
I appreciate it.
There's a lot of important news
we got to get to,
so let's get to the monologue.
But first,
we have a great show tonight.
Robert De Niro is here,
Oscar-winning film legend
Robert De Niro.
He's doing something cool
with his Tribeca Film Festival,
which had to be moved
because of the pandemic.
He has now a new idea
that Jane Rosenthal came up with
which is drive-ins,
Tribeca drive-in movies.
It's a great idea. I'm going
to talk to him about that.
Then James Blake, tennis legend
and also best-selling author,
talks about his experience
with mistaken identity
and his experience
with the police
that happened a few years ago
in New York.
Do you remember that, honey?
-Mm-hmm, yeah.
-Yeah. It's wild.
His story is insane.
So I'm happy that he came on the
show to talk to me about that.
And then one of my all-time
favorites, honey, yours, too,
our pal Lenny Kravitz is closing
out the show tonight with his --
Come on.
-Classic.
-Can you get cooler
than Lenny Kravitz?
Can you get cooler?
-I think his daughter,
but that's it.
-Yeah, she's cool.
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But he is so cool.
-It runs in the family.
-Gosh. He's one of those guys
where it's like,
you can give him a wardrobe
and me the same exact wardrobe,
and you'll see the extreme
of "Who wore it better?"
It's like,
he can just do it, man.
You could put a dollhouse
and say, "Dude, make that
into something cool."
He'll just, like, hold it.
He'll hold --
I'm just looking at a dollhouse,
'cause we have dollhouses
all over the house.
But anyways,
he is just the best --
Anyways, he's doing the song
"Believe" tonight,
which is great,
and I appreciate him doing that.
I do love Lenny Kravitz.
Guys, let's get to
some news here.
Well, guys, apparently
the long-running TV show "Cops"
which many people have
considered racist,
has just been canceled.
So now if you want to watch
a bunch of drunk people
embarrass themselves, you'll
have to watch "The Bachelor"
or "Real Housewives"
or "Below Deck"
or "Below Deck: Med"
or "Below Deck Sail--"
No, just kidding.
Most people are glad
"Cops" has been canceled,
although it's tough news
for stoners who love watching
shirtless guys
try to fail to hop a fence.
"Cops" was a crazy show.
It actually had more
naked and afraid people
than "Naked and Afraid."
"Cops" first aired in 1989,
but really, they just aired the
same three episodes for 30 years
and nobody noticed.
It's not just TV shows
that are being canceled.
Some movies are being removed
from streaming platforms
until they can return
with historical context.
-This morning,
an American cinema classic,
"Gone with the Wind,"
has been temporarily pulled
by the streaming platform
HBO Max.
For years, the movie has been
considered controversial
for its depiction
of black people
and its glorification
of slavery.
-A lot of conservatives
were upset,
to which everyone else said,
"Frankly, my dear,
I don't give a damn."
To anyone who is upset,
really? You're going to watch
a four-hour movie from 1939
this weekend? That's what
you're planning on doing?
You had the whole time
during the quarantine.
But this weekend is when
you were going to watch
"Gone with the Wind"?
In the meantime,
if you still want to watch
something super offensive,
"Cats" is available on demand.
No, that's -- Come on.
Yep, by pulling the film,
HBO Max accomplished
something very important --
They got people
to talk about HBO Max.
And what actually is it?
Meanwhile, Quibi is so desperate
for attention,
they were like, "We'll take it.
We're going to break it up into
300 parts."
And it's not just entertainment.
Now businesses are also dealing
with these issues,
some better than others.
-CrossFit CEO Greg Glassman
has resigned after outrage
over a controversial post
about George Floyd.
A tweet Saturday linked
Floyd's death to the pandemic.
-Yeah, the CEO of CrossFit
stepped down.
Actually, first, he stepped up
and then down and then up again,
then down, then up, and then
he stepped down finally.
Then when he left the building,
instead of driving off,
he just flipped
a giant tire home.
What was he thinking?
He mocked the protests and
the coronavirus in one tweet.
He shouldn't be
the CEO of CrossFit.
He should be the president
of the United States.
Yep, he hit coronavirus
and police brutality.
He just needs to weigh in
on gender,
and he'll finish the triathlon
of offending people.
Well, it seems like
things are slowly changing.
In fact, the Army says
that it might rename
forts that are named after
Confederate officers
like Fort Bragg and Fort Hood.
Yeah, they want new names
that everyone can get behind,
so they did a poll on
what Americans love right now,
and I think they solved
their problem. Take a look.
Fort Bragg is being renamed
Fort Free Guac.
Fort Hood is changing to
Fort Coming Up With
A Good Comeback In The Moment,
And Not In The Shower
The Next Day.
Fort Benning will be
Fort Getting The Capri-Sun Straw
Into The Pouch On The First Try.
And finally, Fort Pickett
will be Fort BTS.
Let's see how that works.
A lot of people are saying
the only way to achieve racial
justice is to go out and vote.
But take a look at what happened
when people tried to vote
in Georgia yesterday.
-Georgia's election
is being called a catastrophe,
particularly in
largely minority areas.
The Secretary of State
is opening an investigation
after reports of long waits,
voting machines not working,
and a lack of ballots
in some areas.
-You know you did a bad job
with your election
when you make Iowa's election
look good.
Seriously, it's not a good sign
when "The Masked Singer" is
better at running an election
than an entire state.
And finally, everybody,
hopefully this might
lift up your spirits.
The Dalai Lama
is actually releasing an album
featuring some of his teachings
and mantras set to music.
And actually,
he even released a song
to help people deal with what's
going on in the world right now.
Let's take a listen.
[ Man screaming,
heavy metal music playing ]
Alright, stop, stop. That's --
Are we sure
that's the right song?
I mean, we're in a quarantine,
so the producers --
Anyway, we're doing what we can.